jojo siwa and her girlfriend kylie peru
are spending time
at the happiest place on earth it's just
awesome
the dance moms alum took to instagram to
share photos of the two during their
trip to disney world
in one clip the couple shows major pda
hugging each other on the vintage
amphicar
as they dive into disney springs and on
splash mountain they got close once
again
kylie putting her arm around the 17 year
old entertainer giving a thumbs up to
the camera
it also looks like this trip was a
family affair with jojo's mom
dad and brother along for the ride
writing in the caption quote
i'm happy so so so happy i love that
that's my favorite thing ever
in january jojo came out as a member of
the lgbtq plus community when she wore
this shirt and retweeted and liked posts
from fans and celebrities praising her
for being a part of the community
i think coming out has this stigma
around it that it's a
really really really scary thing
but it's not anymore there's so many
accepting
and loving people out there that it's
okay it's of course it's people are
gonna say it's not normal but it's your
normal nothing is normal
literally not one thing about anybody is
normal and a month later
jojo revealed she was in a relationship
during an appearance on the tonight show
starring jimmy fallon
because it is true i do have the most
amazing
wonderful perfect most beautiful
girlfriend
on their one-month anniversary jojo
introduced kylie on instagram
describing her as the most loving
supportive happiest protective
and just the most beautiful perfect
person in the world a similar sentiment
she shared during her speech
at the 2021 glad media awards i have
the best most amazing wonderful
girlfriend in the entire world who makes
me
so so so happy and that is all that
matters
i think it's really cool now that kids
all around the world
who who look up to me can now see
that loving who you want to love is
totally
awesome and speaking of jojo's fans the
pop star will turn 18
in may and despite growing older she
assures her fans
for now they can still expect the same
signature jojo
everyone is like you're gonna be 18 are
you gonna change the show and i'm like
no people are coming to see me and my
unicorn they're coming to see
me and my big bow they're coming to see
me staying with bobo they're coming to
see
me living on a rainbow bridge that's
what they want to see give them
give the people what they want you know
everyone wants to have a good time and a
good night
and i think eventually you know i will
grow up past that and i think cobb the
unicorn will have a lovely garage in my
house one day and always be a part of my
life and i think
my front door will always have a hair
bow on it it's who i am